[upbeat music]
male narrator: When it comes
to making money from your app,
always start
by focusing on quality.
A high-quality app
will get better ratings,
which will lead to
more downloads,
which will result in
more revenue.
Here are ten tips
that successful developers use
once their app is ready.
The developer console
can automatically convert
your app price
to local currencies worldwide,
but exchange rates don't reflect
local expectations
and purchasing power,
so research
local economic conditions
and interests thoroughly.
If you think users may be put
off by the price of your app,
but you know they'll see
the value in it once they're in,
make it free to download
and try the app.
After a set time, you can offer
them a one-time purchase
to unlock the app forever.
A free app is a great way
to overcome any barriers
created by price,
and you can offer extras
to users for a price
once they're engaged.
Create a free app
with core features
to engage the user
and then offer extended features
using in-app purchases
such as removing ads,
adding enhanced functionality,
adding in-game items.
As an alternative to selling
digital goods in your apps,
particularly where you have
recurring content costs,
you can sell content and
features with a subscription.
You can offer your users
a free trial to introduce them,
followed by
a recurring subscription
at a variety of intervals,
like weekly, monthly,
or annually.
If you offer a subscription
in your app,
providing users with additional
content or features on your site
can add value
to your subscription
and make it more appealing.
Sign users into your website
and then verify their
Google Play subscription details
to enable features
or content on the web.
Google Analytics provides
invaluable information
on the behavior of users
in your app.
You can use behavior flows
to understand how users are
navigating through your app
and where they drop off.
This information can help
e-commerce apps
optimize purchase flow
or game app developers see
which levels are too difficult
and when players
should be offered help.
You can use this information to
make your app experience better,
while increasing conversions
of install to paying users.
Users can discover your app
in many ways
and now you can find out
exactly which source
is proving the most effective.
The user acquisition performance
report in the developer console
will show you how many users
visit your store listing,
how many go on
to install your app,
and how many make purchases.
You'll see where your most
valuable users come from
so you know where to focus
your efforts.
Users who are already familiar
with your apps
are great prospects
for your other offerings.
If you generate revenue
from displaying AdMob ads
in your apps,
you can take advantage
of the House Ads feature,
which lets you take part
of your advertising inventory
and use that to cross-promote
your own apps and games.
Users who have already bought
in-app products
are good prospects
for future purchases,
so let them know
what's on offer.
Do this using free AdMob
House Ads.
Create in-app House Ads
and AdMob will automatically
figure out
which of your users
are likely to spend
and show them these ads.
AdMob will continue to show
standard ads to other users.
Retaining your existing users
can be an effective use
of marketing dollars.
With AdWords reengagement
campaigns,
you can reach users
who have installed your app
but not used it lately,
or active users who haven't
fully explored it yet.
As users search Google,
AdWords displays your ads
to them
so you can remind them
of key features
or show them special offers.
And with app indexing,
you can link the user to the
specific page in your app
that's relevant to them.
If you want more tips
on how to increase your app
or game's revenue
and build a better app business,
download The Secrets to App
Success on Google Play.